Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and this is an introduction to a book which is
quite to be a different kind of book because it's going to be a video book and you're
going to get videos just like this.
The book is Cancer Genes on Genetics, it can be both a cause and a cure, but we use it
word very lightly because currently I don't believe anybody is cured from cancer or less
cloud intervenes completely, I believe we all have cancer and that even when we go into
full remission, and even when an oncologist says you are completely cancer-free, you are
never completely cancer-free, that's why when it does come back with a vengeance of different
people, then it never did come back with a vengeance because it was never gone.
So dealing with cancer is a serious disease, and dealing with cancer leads you to become
serious about just take one person's word for anything you want to dig into things, and
this is why I dig into things like your genetics.
We're not just looking at tuber suppressor genes, which many people have come to me and
said, oh we've had my genes all run, look at them and they've had 30 genes run, well we
want to look at about 900,000 steps, they look at different steps that are not typically
looked at by other doctors, things that affect your detox pathways, yes your tuber suppressor
genes, different tuber pathways and metabolic pathways that can stimulate both growth and
kid hinder the suppression of cancer, knowing these kind of things and knowing what we're
going to talk about in this book, prior to you ever having to diagnose, so kids here would
be extremely beneficial, so that if you knew you had defects in specific detox pathway,
let's say, you could address that and support that pathway, and maybe you would be more careful
on how you may be hindering that pathway by your diet and exposure to different chemicals
and such so that you can help prevent cancer in the log run and any other serious disease as
well, so very beneficial I think this will be.
So series of videos is what this book is going to be, so it's going to be a little bit different.
We're going to go over important genes related to cancer and recovery from cancer, we're
going to go over genes that give clues to the best diet that a person with cancer might
want to ensue, we're going to go over genes that suggest pieces of cause like that detox
pathway defects and such, we're going to go over genes maybe less related to cancer but
give a bigger overall picture of a person's health, so even if you don't have cancer, this
series may be very helpful for you, we're going to go over things that you may want
to relate to your offspring because if you have defects in certain pathways, you may
pass those on to your children, so it could be very beneficial for them to know what's going
on as well to help prevent some of the problems that you've had.
Make sure we understand the understandings we are not making any health claims in this
book, you need to consult your doctor, this is not a substitute for your general psychological
health care, the legalities of this are, this is my information and I'm passing on my
information to you things that I'm searching for for my patients and my own health and my
own family, and it's my opinion that you don't take this irresponsibly, but you take this
back to your current doctor if I'm not in and communicate that with your current doctor
and maybe make some changes in your life, so this is meant to be also an ongoing living
video book, I'll be adding videos constantly to this and it will be continued to grow as
new information comes up, but even do information, may contradict old information, so stay
up with the videos, alright thank you very much.